that's when queenie came to the hospital
and she said oh yeah who is queenie to
you so she came up she came up to visit
queenie stopped by our house
a couple of years ago maybe even three
or four years ago
she was a fan of my husband's and she
wanted some
she she's a she's a catholic she
um lives uh on
u of t campus she is like a dorm
dawn for
catholic girls at u of t
but she also does other things she's
very interested in family
she's very interested in schooling and
family and
things that have gone i think she
contacted us
when our prime minister
and our prime minister our premier was
kathleen wynne
i think that's when she first came to
our house because she was concerned
about the
curriculum and the things that were
happening in schools
and she was i don't know she was just
this friendly little asian woman
and she came to the
she came to the hospital and she brought
me a rosary and she said do you want to
pray
i said sure why not
let's pray so i
grabbed my i had my bag in my pool and
we'd go down in the toronto general
there's a an atrium with
it's four stories high and it's full of
plants and sunshine
a little bit like being outside so i
could go down there you must love that
i loved that that was like life you know
to me that was good
so i'd go down there and i would sit
with her for two hours
and cry and pray
okay so what gave you this idea to do
this on a regular basis did you
already know that talk therapy was
curative in a psychological or physical
sense
no no she just she just showed up and
asked me if i wanted to do it and i just
said yes
so i think she knew
because you know there's a there's a
in in catholicism there are prayer
um organized prayer
sessions that people can set up or you
can you can belong to a part of the
church that's all about prayer
so i belong to a part of the church
that's all about prayer and it's about
just everyday people praying for life
that's what they do is they pray
and so that's what i do as i pray
and so you went down with her to the
toronto general atrium
and every day you talked for two dollars
i mean sorry everything you talked not
for two dollars for two
for two hours she didn't charge anything
nope she just came
gave me a gave me a rosary and we prayed
and then i would go back upstairs and
play cards with my family
and visit with them and i just stayed
there for five weeks
praying and then just before i went to
pennsylvania
to a doctor who was hopefully going to
heal this hole i had in my abdomen
um i she she asked if i wanted a priest
to come over and bless me and i said
sure
and so a priest that works with
eric father eric he works at u of t
he came over to our apartment and he
blessed me and he
gave me the novena for the ill
which are nine days of prayer for
someone who's deathly
ill and told me to
meditate on gratitude and
off i went to university of pennsylvania
with my with a lot with plenty of my
family along with me
and they
were supposed to be the best in the
world
and i'm sure they are they did an mri
guided
they poked little needles in me with dye
and poppy seed oil
and they said now and then the poppy
seed oil will irritate
it will irritate the system and and if
there's a
um a leak somewhere it will be irritated
enough
that the body will put down um
whatever kind of um tissue is necessary
i see i see just scar it up and close it
and so they looked for the leak couldn't
find it
so sorry the poppy seed oil is for
imaging purposes the poppy seed oil is
to carry the dye
i see okay and then on the mri they can
see plumes come
out if there's a leak ah cool cool cool
yeah cool cool cool very cool very cool
very cool so they tried to look for it
they couldn't find it
they couldn't find it that means the
poppy seed oil worked instantly
no it didn't work instantly no they
couldn't find it i was still leaking
i was leaking it was thursday
by saturday it had kind of slowed down
the leaking
but we'd had the leaking slow down
already once before and then found out
it was just a mechanical
failure of the of the bag
apparatus that i had hooked to me so uh
right so then so it was false positive
so no no
that so this time when it slowed down we
were going so is this
better or is this just because things
aren't
properly cared for here or like so
what's going on what's going on
and they had told me that the only way
to tell
if the lymph had healed would be to eat
some fat
so at that point i was eating food again
but no fat
a no fat diet like i had done before
that would when irritate the lymph yep
because the lymph is works with fat
so if you don't put any fat down the
lymph isn't working
and you want to limit what the lymph is
doing if you have
but you also mentioned that the lymph
serves as a garbage collector in your
body
so no matter what it would be working
but at a much lesser rate
yeah right okay much lesser rate okay
yeah
so on saturday i thought well i might as
well eat some fat and see if this has
worked or not
because on monday they're going to open
me up and do some
more major surgery to see what they can
find
so i might as well find out if it worked
before of that
and so okay i had i don't know
i think i had eggs not just the
white but the yolk
and as far as i could tell there was no
milky looking fluid in my bag it still
looked like
urine it was just yellow
and so the next morning i was at
breakfast and an intern and a nurse came
and they said well you know i think you
better eat some fat because we have to
find out
if you still if the leak is still like
what's going on there and so i said well
i already ate some
fat last night they said oh okay well
like show me what's in the bag and i
pulled it up and it was clear
and they said
this is you know this isn't what we
expected
we're very surprised your leak seems to
have
closed up and you're better you can go
home
so then they followed me for about a
month told me just to walk
not do anything else not lift anything
or anything and
they called me often and then after a
month they said well you're discharged
you're better
so i prayed then the
novena for five days and then i was
better